[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning are you gonna wake up every
morning with a big smile on our face and
show the world all the love in our
hearts and that love in our hearts is
about fairness and valuing work House
Democrats are here to deliver on the
promise to the American people to give
hard-working men and women a
well-deserved raise we salute our
chairman Bobby Scott who's managing the
bill on the floor and some of us will
come and go to speak on the floor as we
convey our message this morning but his
work was indispensable to getting us to
this place working with members to come
to consensus but we would not be here
without the outside mobilized mobilizing
so thank you all for being here
[Applause]
I especially want to salute President
Mary Kay Henry of SEIU for her 10 years
have passed since we passed an increase
in the minimum wage
Democrats and the majority President
Bush signed the bill and it was a pretty
exciting it was I have to say when we
passed the bill House and Senate knew
that the president was going to sign the
bill we went outside and had a big rally
and not that rally president excuse me
senator Ted Kennedy who was an important
part of this as the chairman of propria
Committee in the Senate after we we had
all of our conversation speeches as now
he said you know what we have to do now
we have to raise the minimum wage right
away
we've just had done that but he knew he
knew that we had to do more so now we're
in the majority again and here we have
in that 10 years our families struggle
to make ends meet their cost of living
has surged inflation has eaten at their
wages and the GOP special interests
agenda Genda has left them behind
America's workers deserve a raise
why we're so happy this morning is this
the raise the wage act gives up to 33
million Americans a long-overdue raised
33 million Americans endless and there's
so many people out of poverty this bill
honors the dignity of work grows the
economy and upholds the bedrock idea of
fairness in our country that hard work
deserves a decent wage today we're proud
to pass this legislation 171 years to
the day that the Seneca Falls convention
the Seneca Falls condemns a convention
stated a simple proclamation that all
men and women are created equal this is
the anniversary of that statement this
bill helps to achieve that equality by
giving nearly 20 million working women
nearly one third of all working women in
our country third a 20 million working
women are raised and that is an applause
it also helps narrow the gender wage gap
that targets women of color putting more
money in the pockets of more than one
third of working women of color so this
is really important I mentioned Ted
Kennedy's comments as soon as we
finished one time for another and now
this long overdue but substantial we'll
never stop fighting for the people and
for the progress of working families
across America now here's the thing
our agenda when we ran was for the
people lower health care costs bigger
paychecks today we're talking about
bigger paychecks with the important
legislation we also passed as you will
pay for equal work so this is all in
that in that space keeping that promise
now is my pleasure - I want to again
acknowledge the great work of our
distinguished chairman Bobby Scott who
came into the chairmanship in January
focused on this day he will be joining
us momentarily but at the moment I have
the distinct pleasure of bringing to the
podium our distinguished Majority Leader
Steny Hoyer of Maryland
[Applause]
the speaker is going to the floor and
she's going to speak to the American
people and to the members of the house
and say why it is so important that we
raise the wage the speaker mentioned
that we campaigned on really two
particular points the first of course
was reform which we passed HR 1 to make
our government more open more honest and
more trained
you
they needed and thirdly we said we were
going to raise wages this is a promise
made and today a promise will be kept
[Applause]
you
I was the majority leader and I brought
it to the floor
I am the majority leader today and we've
been waiting too long but it's never too
late to do the right thing and we
brought the minimum wage to the floor
and it's going to pass on the floor we
have now seen that the longest time
between raising the minimum wage since
it was adopted in the New Deal in the
30s too long to allow people to be stuck
at a wage while their cost of their
groceries goes up their cost of their
mortgage goes up the cost of everything
they do is going up and they're stuck
that's not fair that's not right that's
not what America should be doing and
very frankly yes it will benefit people
on the minimum wage but it's gonna
advantage all of America all of America
is gonna be advanced good we're gonna
ride spend and we're gonna buy groceries
gonna buy clothes they're gonna buy
things they need too many Americans are
struggling to get by and unable to
invest in getting ahead according to the
Economic Policy Institute as the speaker
said raising the minimum wage to $15 an
hour will increase wages for up to 33
million people that's ten percent of
America ten percent of America is going
to get a raise by this bill ten percent
of America is going to be more able to
have a better quality of life ten
percent of America's going to be able to
be better
contributing cents citizens to
themselves to their families and to
America they deserve equal pay for equal
work I thank chairman Scott and the
others who worked on writing this bill
for recognizing this important issue of
civil rights and equal justice requiring
the same minimum wage for those with
disabilities I was the sponsor of the
Americans with Disabilities Act the
intent was to include and to Bank into
those who had a disability this spill
will advance the goal of economic
self-sufficiency promised by the
Americans with Disabilities Act which I
was proud to help pass in 1990 and
George HW Bush signed in 1990 the house
will pass the raise the wage act today
as I have said and I hope the Senate I
hope the Senate I hope the Senate will
pass it as well now let me introduce
somebody of mine he and I have known
each other for about four and a half
minutes
and he's become a really good friend
already he's a really terrific person
she is terrific person Fran Marion is
from Kansas City Missouri and works at
McDonald's
I hate to admit this well I really don't
I hate it McDonald's all the time and I
want to see friend paid what is deserved
for the work that she does get me a good
hamburger good french fries with a good
milkshake
thank you so much sir
as I was saying my name is Fran Marion
I'm a single mother of two teenagers
Raven and Rashad and I work at
McDonald's in Kansas City and I've been
working fast food most of my adult life
I joined the fight for 15 and Union five
years ago
and I've been standing up with my
co-workers ever since demanding $15 and
a voice on our job and today I'm so very
proud and honored to stand here in
Washington DC on a verge of a historic
victory a vote for a $15 minimum wage in
the US House of Representatives
I want to thank every member of Congress
about to vote YES on this bill for
standing with me the other workers in
this room and the working class across
the country even though I worked in fast
food for more than two decades
McDonald's barely pays enough to support
myself let alone my kids the company
makes six billion and that's billions
with a B in profits last year alone but
the people who work there like myself
have to rely on food stamps and Medicaid
just have a chance for our planning's
have a chance at survival if that's what
you want to call it my families even
been homeless even while I was working
six days a week my daughter just
graduated from high school and I'd love
to be able to support her plans for
college
my son plays high school football and
also has dreams of going to college one
day but right now I can't even afford to
invest in my kids future it's just not
right I want my children have a better
future that's why a fifteen dollar
minimum wage is so important to me I
don't mean I don't have to scramble and
stress at the end of the month just to
pay the bills
it'll mean unlike workers like me can
afford food and healthcare for ourselves
and for our children and more
importantly it'll support their dreams
for a better life a life better than
mine and what 200 workers walked off the
job in New York City in 2012 the madding
facing dollars in the union nobody gave
him a shot but I demand it has caught
fire since the fight for 15 and Union
began more than 24 million workers I 170
billion in raises but in Kansas City we
weren't so lucky
and we sponsor our movement voters
passed by passing $15 by setting for 2
cent of the vote but our state
legislature legislature excuse me block
the raise that's why it's so important
that we need a $15.00 federal minimum
wage and that's why I'm so happy that
the House members are voting YES are
standing with us today
[Applause]
even though we're celebrating today we
know our fight is not over
tomorrow we'll turn right back to the
fight so beyond the Senate as well as on
president Trump but there also be on
McDonald's as well McDonald's doesn't
need to wait for the Senate or wait for
the president it can do what's right for
workers what's right for America raise
Raiders ar-15 win when we're going to
give them dollars and pay $15 and we're
going to win 15 across the country the
same way we've gotten cities States
companies and the US House to raise pay
to $15 by coming together speaking up
and going on strike as we say on our
strike lines we work we sweat but 15 on
our check we work we sweat but 15 on our
checks all right we sweat but 15 on our
checks thank you
thank you six months ago we stood here
in this room together to announce the
introduction of the raise the wage act
and I'm proud to say that today later
today the house will pass that bill and
this will be the first time in 12 years
that a chamber of Congress approves an
increase to the federal minimum wage
it's been stuck at 7.25 75 cents an hour
for a decade even though the cost of
living in this country has skyrocketed
and let me be clear we are going to
secure this important victory which is
one battle in our broader fight on
behalf of hard-working American families
we are going to secure this victory
because the bill's advocates in and out
of Congress have been willing to make
principled compromises the bill we
consider today is not the same bill that
was filed six months ago but because
we've had honest conversations
good-faith negotiations and a unified
commitment to getting this done the
house is about to pass a strong bill
that would boost wages for an estimated
30 million families this bill is a
beautiful example of how the legislative
process should work in a country as
democratic and as diverse as ours I I
support this bill for a simple yet
powerful reason in the greatest country
on Earth no person who has the dignity
of a full-time job should suffer the
indignity of not being able to provide
for themselves or their loved ones my
Orlando district is a powerful case in
point it has a relatively high cost of
living and the lowest median household
income of the 50 largest metropolitan
areas in the country and although it is
slightly above the federal minimum wage
the Florida minimum wage is not a living
wage workers in my district cannot be
self-sufficient and support their
families on this wage and this is a
painful fact of life for
many people in my state and across this
country and at the same time I subscribe
to the view that you cannot be Pro
worker unless you are also pro-business
since most American workers are hired
and retained by businesses and I
counseled startups when I used to work
in the private sector and my husband is
a small business owner and I would not
support this bill if I thought it would
harm small business owners or their
employees to the contrary this
legislation will provide a much-needed
boost to businesses both small and large
into the broader economy
if lower income workers are paid a
living wage they will have more money in
their pockets nearly every economist
will tell you that when working families
earn more money they spend it in their
local community boosting sales creating
jobs and strengthening the economy for
everyone and when I vote YES on this
bill later today I'll be thinking about
my own parents hardworking refugees from
Vietnam who worked multiple low-wage
jobs and struggled to make ends meet and
it will be one of the proudest votes I
cast in this Congress
I'm honored to have been a part of this
team effort to achieve a win for working
families in the United States Senate and
in state capitals across this country
our fight goes on thank you and now I'd
like to yield to Alyssa Barron Menza
who's the vice president of business for
a fair minimum wage my name is Alyssa
Barron Menza and I'm vice president of
business for a fair minimum wage a
national network of owners executives
and business organizations who believe a
fair minimum wage makes good business
sense
about a thousand business organizations
owners and executives have signed our
business for a fair minimum wage
statement supporting raising the federal
minimum wage to $15 and more are signing
every day they range from small
businesses in Alabama and Kansas and all
across the country to big national
brands to the u.s. women's Chamber of
Commerce raising the minimum wage will
be good for business good for customers
and good for the economy we need to
remember that workers are also customers
businesses need customers with money to
spend raising the minimum wage puts
money in the hands of people who most
need to spend it in the words of
Louisiana Small Business Person of the
Year Angela O'Byrne increasing the
federal minimum wage will create ripple
effects benefiting businesses large and
small raising the minimum wage makes
good business sense in other ways low
pay typically means high employee
turnover raising the minimum wage saves
businesses money in lower turnover and
reduced hiring and training costs
businesses also see lower error and
accident rates increased productivity
and better customer service employees
often make the difference between repeat
customers or lost customers this
increase will not happen overnight
raising the floor gradually gives
businesses time to plan and adjust while
experiencing benefits such as increased
consumer spending lower turnover and
higher productivity raising the minimum
wage will boost the economy and help
mrs. thrive it's time to get this done
and now I have the honor of yielding to
the congressman I'm very glad to be here
at co-chair the Progressive Caucus with
Pramila Jaya Paul of Washington State
and I have to admit I was just on the
floor we both were debating this bill
and I found it interesting and maybe the
right word is incredible that people who
make a hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars a year half of which are
millionaires are telling people who make
minimum wage $15,000 a year that they
have to learn to tighten their belts
perhaps they should ask him if they can
afford a new belt at $15,000 a year
American workers are the most productive
and best workers in the world but in
many industries wages have stagnated and
the share going to profits and the top
1% has soared the raise the wage Act
would give a well-deserved raised to
nearly 1/4 of the workforce 33 million
people no family in the United States
can live on seven and a quarter an hour
and make ends meet in my home state of
Wisconsin you would have to work 93
hours a week in order to afford a modest
two-bedroom apartment and there's not a
single country in the county in the
country where a worker earning the
minimum wage can afford a two-bedroom
apartment on minimum wage I come to
Congress with three decades as a small
business owner small business owners
know that workers our customers our
neighbors and our community when workers
have more money in their pockets they
have more money to spend for their
families and they stimulate the economy
this is especially true in rural areas
like my district where workers have only
a handful of employment options if the
primary employer in a rural town is a
multi-billion dollar corporation like
Walmart or McDonald's they can afford to
pay their workers $15 an hour instead of
holding down wages for the entire
community
today is a very good day because we are
about to break a record we just set the
longest stretch in US history without a
hike in the minimum wage it is long past
you that we show workers the respect
they deserve by putting more money in
their pockets and I think everyone for
being here today let's pass this bill
and give the American people a raise I'm
supposed to recognize Bobby Scott but I
think he's still on the floor he has
done an amazing job on this bill it is
my honor to next introduce and i hope i
pronouncing it correctly Trupti patel
[Applause]
good morning everybody my name is my
name is strip deep its own I'm a member
of the restaurant opportunities centers
United I'm also the daughter of Indian
immigrants and I'm a first generation
American I've worked in the restaurant
industry for more than seven years I'm
here to thank speaker Pelosi leader
Hoyer many members of Congress and all
the workers and advocates who stand
behind me who've worked so hard to bring
this
[Applause]
there are millions of people who work
for tips and we only make 213 an hour
and we haven't gotten a raise in 28
years and that's unacceptable we need to
change that we are professionals and as
members as hard-working professionals
who have years of experience I demand
that we get the same wage as other
professionals in other industries the
tips minimum wage is a vestige of
slavery because after emancipation
employers demanded the right to hire
newly freed slaves and not pay them
anything and just say live off tips the
generosity of strangers we have to stop
segregating restaurant workers or today
primarily people of color and women
because when women make to only 213 an
hour we have to put up with customers
saying and doing inappropriate things
just to get the tips we need to feed our
own families I want the freedom to make
a fair wage directly from my employer
before tips I want the freedom to know
how much money I will make each week and
the freedom to budget for my life I
stand in solidarity with my brothers and
sisters in the restaurant industry and
demanding one fair wage if you pass this
bill you will be the first in the
history of the United States to vote to
end this endless legacy of slavery and
give tip workers that same minimum wage
as everybody else
we need you to do the right thing we
need you to pass this bill some say I
look like I serve America but I came to
shatter the glass ceiling in America
good morning Don Norris from Bradley
from southern New Jersey and a former
minimum wage workers 219 hour I was a
single dead it was tough to make it back
then it's impossible today but I think
we should start by thanking speaker and
Majority Leader and certainly Bobby
Scott and all of you for keeping this on
the forefront of America less than two
years ago our colleagues on the other
side of the I've decided those in the
top 1% it needed a little bit more of a
raise right so they can invest in that
second ship overseas another house while
they were stepping on the workers that
are here today a decade since we voted
to raise the minimum wage it will be 17
years so this is fully implemented
that's us some 45 cents an hour per year
and they're sitting in there crying with
crocodile tears saying it's too much
saying it's too much try to go out and
live on 725 now or anybody making it no
not at all this is America you work hard
you play by the rules you're supposed to
be able to make it but what do we do
with finally after 11 years ago to set
the record straight Henry Ford said it
right you need to pay workers enough to
buy your goods and services it doesn't
take a genius to figure that out but we
have two different worlds
those on the other side of the aisle who
think they can step on us to keep their
money and then we have the reality the
dignity of going to work and earning a
decent pay and that's what we're going
to do we're going to help
America get a raise thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's about family it's about our
children catching your Arbonne our VIP
today I say to my grandchildren do you
want to go down the slide this is about
family $7.25 an hour pay to workers
while the federal government has to
subsidize food stamps housing support
health care different in different ways
and that's I mean how why should we be
subsidizing businesses or exploiting
workers by paying $7.25 an hour that was
12 years ago when we passed it when we
were first in the majority as we've all
said the purchasing power of that money
has gone down and the value of work has
not has increased so this is part of our
bigger paychecks part of our for the
people agenda we've passed equal pay for
equal work under the leadership of rosa
DeLauro today we pass this legislation
to raise the minimum wage to $15 an hour
so exciting we will be yesterday we
passed an ordering lowering health care
costs we passed the repeal of the
Cadillac tax and next week we'll be
passing legislation to support fairness
and our pensions for workers so this is
about workers it's about their economic
and financial security and today today
is a bright day because it affects so
many people in our
I want to thank our special special
guest friend Marion not that our members
of Congress aren't our special guests
and we're very proud of and Alisa Baron
lissa right here oh my go
and Anja trucky Patel your first they
really are again along with Cassidy our
VIPs they speak for so many people were
honored by your presence we want to
honor your work by increasing the
minimum wage thank you
[Applause]